When you first have an idea for
a game, it's often pretty complex.
You might imagine a story with lots of
interesting graphics and enemies, but
the core of the game is
usually very simple.
And this core is the first
thing you want to test out
before you distribute your
game to a wider audience.
You want to make sure your
game foundation is strong,
by testing it out with
a small group of players.
To test your game core, you need
to create a minimum viable product
which is the simplest most
focused version of your game.
Minimum means it contains
the minimum amount of features
that encapsulate the game,
no extra levels or graphics.
Let's look at some a examples
of a minimum viable product.
Consider the game Megatroid which is a
platformer a game where you jump through
stages, getting upgrades and shooting
robot enemies to advance levels.
You can even generate
your own playable levels.
This game has a lot of fun features, but
what do we need in
the minimum viable product?
Level creation?
No.
Enemies?
Weapon upgrades, or even weapons at all?
No.
These are all extra features that
can be added later in the game.
To test the foundation of the game,
we need to remove all the enemies,
items and extra levels,
all the things that are nice to have but
not necessary to have.
And what we're left with is
a single jumping platform game.
To make a Megatroid
minimum viable product, I
would include just a single level where
I can move and jump and fall into pits.
I might also include an easy restart for
the game.
This defines the basic
structure of my game.
These are the minimum needed features,
and
they're the most important to perfect.
We want to test this version out and
make sure that the game movement is as
smooth and high quality as possible.
Then we can add enemies and
upgrades later on.
So when you're thinking about what to
include in your minimum viable product,
think about what features are needed for
your game to be entertaining and
what can be added later.